[Music]
i really appreciate you taking the time
to do this today and
i've been looking forward to it my
pleasure
we're going to bounce around quite a bit
i will make sure that we touch on
burning questions and
certainly practical utopias but
i have so many questions about
just your life and life energy
and we can come at it from so many
different directions i want to begin
with a few questions if it's okay with
you from someone on my team who is a
huge fan of yours and
it relates to
your writing or it's a creative process
and
in the research that i've done
it seems like you tend not to outline
books before you start writing them at
least the quote that i have here is
never map it out just get into it jump
in like going swimming is that accurate
that's pretty pretty right yes you you
have to uh
factor in the going swimming part is
about a very cold lake so we're not
talking about florida here
uh or pools we're talking about
screaming
running screaming
right so when you sit down to write and
this is her question one of her
questions do you know at the start
whether it will be poetry or prose or
specific project i do know that
you do yeah i actually do know that and
poetry is more
likely to be written on the run
or on the fly and not necessarily
sitting down
could you expand on that please
i always write poetry in something
called cursive you may have forgotten
about that tim i know cursive
apparently they're not always teaching
cursive to young people so we're going
to have a whole generation who don't
know how to sign their names they will
only know how to print their names
anyway yes cursive which we were all
taught in school with scratching little
metal nibs that you dipped in ink wells
you probably didn't do that because they
probably had ball points by your day i
used ball points
but my grandfather was an actual
well he was in part a calligrapher so i
spent a lot of time around inkwells my
grandfather spent a lot of time in
calligraphy oh extremely classy yeah
very classy yes i've bought several
calligraphy sets intending to use them
but tim i haven't used them yet
but i'm going to i'm going to i'm going
to do that
if we look at the poetry and the prose
do they come from different places
within yourself do they have a different
feeling
it's my theory but you can't ever test
it out without great cruelty
i guess what cats don't write poetry or
anything else oh so it has to be people
that you would practice the great
cruelty on
so you would have to wire up their heads
you can wire up their heads for novels
no problem because you know novels it's
10
inspiration and 90 perspiration so you
actually have to work at writing novels
it's called work
you have to sit down it's like a job you
have to put in the hours
but with poetry it's exactly the the
opposite you don't know
when something may strike you and that's
why poets are so annoying
to people who are not poets because
they'll be looking out the window
and you'll say could you please mow the
lawn and they'll say
don't interrupt no no go away i mean it
can be very annoying
so we we understand why poets often have
quite interesting lives but
i was lucky to be able to do both so
people think i'm moderately sane
you know in the in the bell curve of
poets
and novelists with let's say
well i don't know i mean i guess a lot
of novelists drank a lot too but
let us say that poets are often let's
say their life trajectory is frequently
more erratic
than that of novelists how can we put
this gently
and especially female poets i mean it
was just assumed in the in the 50s that
they were sort of crazy
you don't seem crazy to me well i'm not
but you know i'm the living
demonstration that this isn't true but
it's my theory that
poetry comes from a different
part of the brain and the part that's
more closely allied to patterning
of music mathematics
like that whereas
novels come from the part that is more
closely associated with a gossip
gossip
telling stories about people
telling stories about just about
anything
and narrative so this happens that
happens this happens that happens
and um
that goes all the way back to for
instance homer so you read the iliad in
the odyssey you can see that there's a
narrative
approach
very useful the iliad starts in the
middle of things
and so do a lot of novel so you've got
several ways you can start you can start
at the beginning and go on until you
reach the end or you can start in the
middle
or you can start at the end and then go
back and pick it up but
but poetry lyric poetry is different
epic poetry is more like novels
because it's got lots of stories in it
so my thing about the odyssey is that
it's you know all those westerns in
which
they were holding the fort and the
cavalry was riding to the rescue yes so
the people in the fort didn't know that
and the cavalry didn't know what was
happening in the fort so you've got a
lot of tension
so that's the odyssey so here comes
odysseus nobody knows where he's been
all these years
and there's penelope holding out
uh and just as she's about to give in he
turns up in disguise
you know a lot of stories involve in
disguise
and uh then we go on from there with a
great finale
do you feel like
poetry
enables you
or enlivens you in a way that fuels the
prose work
in other words is there a synergistic
relationship for you between
having both of those outlets or vehicles
yeah so why do i do that because nobody
told me not to
there weren't any
once upon a time tim a long long time
ago and you aren't going to believe this
but there were no creative writing
schools
i believe it so essentially it was open
season you could do whatever you what
you wanted and
there weren't people saying you have to
do either this or that there were no
people like that
so we just did whatever
and it seems to have been true that
i will have written poems about
something and then some years later that
will turn up in
some other form
so for instance i wrote
some poetry
in which this character called grace
marx makes an appearance and then some
years later i wrote a television play
about that
back when television was still black and
white
you don't remember that tim
so many things you don't remember so it
was black and white and
but i was using only one source for that
because this is an historical person
and
the person who had been writing about
grace had got a lot of things wrong
so i did the play
for television
and then years passed
a number of years past maybe about 12
years
and there i was
in switzerland
it would be switzerland you know home of
carl jung
and i started writing this
piece of prose and i thought so who is
this
it's grace marks
and she's dissatisfied with the job i
did in that play
she wants me to go back and take another
look
so this time we went to a lot of sources
not just the one
and
we found this extremely
interesting story because it was it was
several stories and
and there was no resolution you know we
never actually found out through the
historical record whether grace marx had
murdered anybody or not so i wrote a
novel called alias grace and then that
gets turned into a
netflix series miniseries by sarah
pauley
and sarah paulie is an actress director
producer scriptwriter who wrote to me
when she was 17 years old and said i
have to do this
she was 17. i said
so cute
but she did it finally she said it only
took me like 20 years
and she did a great job of it so that's
that story so yeah started as a poem
turned into a television play turned
into a novel and then turned back into a
television series only this time a more
accurate one
i i'm already having so much fun i have
to ask you i'm going to put all of my
questions aside i have just pages and
pages of notes and plans and research
and i'm going to push it all aside for a
second just to ask
what are the things that you do
if anything maybe it's just out of the
box genetics you could speak to that too
to
maintain such
a
vital life energy at 82 years young
because i'm i'm looking for any playbook
and i don't know how much of it is
nature versus nurture but
i would just love any
any tips from the field
because i've i've been impressed with
watching videos of you certainly it's
entirely
more impressive to be having the
conversation with you
what what are some of your other
activities or things that you do
let's begin with the genetics
my mom lived to 97.
my dad not quite so long 86
but my
mom was
very
they were both very curious about things
so there's always something new coming
along
and
you may have noticed that i
dabble in those things from time to time
because i'm interested in them i want to
know how they work
i want to know
there's a there's a good and a bad for
every human technology that we make i
want to know what's the upside what's
the downside
cost benefit but also what are what are
people
using this for because it's so
frequently that we invent something for
one purpose and then
people find a whole different purpose
for it
for lots of purposes for instance
velcro
so i invented velcro had no idea what it
was for
but now we know it's for putting on your
shoes tim
[Laughter]
so curiosity genetics curiosity
and if you want to go to the astrology
we can do that too
you want to go there oh wow
you know i didn't see that coming but
yes let's go to the australians of
course you didn't so what do i know
about astrology because a long long time
ago
i was in english literature
and i was a victorianist
and
one of the things that you had to know
for the kind of english literature that
i was in at that time which began with
anglo-saxon and ended with t.s eliot
was people's world views
and especially as you get into the
renaissance
that's what people believed they
believed in astrology they believed in
palmistry which is connected
and therefore
it was interesting to know about things
because you could see you could for
instance look at a
portrait a renaissance portrait and look
at the rings on the fingers
because what fingers those rings were on
meant something
to the people looking at the picture
and the positions of the hands meant
something so
like this you see a lot of saints going
like this let me see if i can show you
got it so it's sort of palm facing in uh
well no it's the little finger
it's the little finger that's separate
from the rest of the hand oh i see oh
yeah oh yeah
we did that too you know oh this is the
the vulcan handsome we go live live well
and prosper
yeah so our hand gestures still mean
things but our hand gestures have
changed over the years anyway back into
the renaissance they believed in
astrology
and that's when the tarot cards arise
so if you were studying t.s eliot you
had to know something about the tarot
because it turns up in the wasteland
so lucky me i had somebody called
yetzka sabisma living below me and when
i was living in a you know an apartment
and she was from holland
and she was studying hieronymus bosch
the painter
and it was her
thesis back in 1969 that these
funny little figures and ironymus
bosch's weird paintings were not
figments of his freudian subconscious
but they were astrological symbols
so she said about
demonstrating that and during the long
cold edmonton winter nights
when nobody went out because it was very
slippery and cold
and people's car tires froze in squares
jetskas abysmal taught me astrology and
palmistry
so i know those things
so if you want to do the astrology we
can go there tim
i do well with that type of lead-in like
i can't say no okay all i need to tell
you is gemini rising
and you will know what that means
i will not know what that means i need a
footnote
okay very curious tim
very curious
and a bit flighty
so do you identify then with your gemini
rising assessment would you agree with
the astrological read of yourself well
it kind of doesn't matter whether i
agree or not
it is what it is
i just throw it out there for you
because you wanted an explanation as to
why i'm always sticking my nose into
things
and what keeps me going so what keeps me
going is you never know
and the other thing that keeps me going
is
don't open that door never mind
why not i'm going to open the door
is the you never know a reference to why
not trying something new
is is that what that means or does it
mean something else it means that
exactly it means that so just to go a
little deeper into the astrology the
the
governing
planet of gemini
is hermes okay otherwise known as
mercury and what is hermes the god of
he is the god of
thieves
jokes i was going to say handbags but i
don't have my mythology and bags get
they get into it
get into it there's a reason
okay thieves jokes money communications
travel
he's the opener and closer of doors
the garter of secrets
and also the revealer of secrets and the
only one of the gods that can go down to
the underworld and return from it
so he is the conductor of souls to the
underworld
and as you'll recall tim
from the end of the odyssey when now
of course
[Laughter]
when odysseus shoots all these people
he shoots a lot of them really
good shot
it is it is hermes who conducts these
souls to the underworld
he's what we call a psychopath a
conductor of souls to the underworld
so people in my
configuration are very interested in uh
plumbing
the sewer system
underwear
thieves criminals
uh secrets and anything that's buried
like that
so that's where the curiosity comes in
let's dig this up
let's stick this up let's open this door
well you mentioned you know hermes and
aside from the handbag reference which
was only partially joking well that's
pretty good it means roomies governs
money i mean it all makes sense i i know
for those people listening or offended
or amazed i get it but the opening and
closing of doors the opener and closer
of doors it made me think of a book that
i really enjoyed called trickster makes
this world great book i love i know the
author oh really lewis hyatt yes i loved
that book well have you read the gift
his first book
the gift didn't grab me in the same way
although i know many many many people
who would put that up in their top three
five books in terms of influence in
their lives so i should probably give it
another shot well i think trickster make
this makes this world is more pertinent
to you oh
as a trickster
i like that i'm just gonna let that
float in the in the air yes well that
this is this is the business that you're
in you're you're in that that side of
the hermes constellation
gift on the other hand is very useful
for people going into the arts
because it differentiates quite clearly
the world of of commerce
uh from the world of the arts
although if you're in the arts
you may get your inspiration as a gift
but at some point you have to go through
the valley of the shadow of commerce
to get to the other side where your your
thing whatever it is turns back into a
gift in the hands of the
recipient say the ideal reader
so you write the book that's in the
world of gift it then gets turned into
this thing with pages and everything and
it gets some something called sold
so it's in the world of commerce
but somebody who then reads your book on
the other hand and loves it doesn't say
uh well i didn't get 22.95 worth out of
this book i mean some people do but
usually they don't say that
whereas they might say that about an
automobile that they bought you know the
seat belts don't work i want you to fix
them
uh you do that with with things that you
have bought
but things that you have received as a
gift you you do not do that too
you you do however have obligations
towards gifts you need to
pass them on you do not keep them you
need to either give somebody else a gift
or pass on the gift that you have
received in some way so i do recommend
it if you want to understand some of the
odd ways of artists i did very much
enjoy the sections i did read about gift
economies and the circulation exactly of
gift yes i think trickster makes this
world applies to you as well and the
reason i say that
is there's a term used in that book that
i very much
loved and i highlighted i think the
description was related to coyote as one
of the archetypes here but as a boundary
walker and i view you also as a as a
boundary walker between the the present
and the possible right and there's i've
in the course of doing research for this
conversation read about
the
the different ways we could look at the
semantics of say science fiction some
other planet with creatures never before
seen versus speculative fiction
where you're taking something that
exists or is in the process of becoming
and then taking it a few steps out and
you seem to be a master of that which
would make you a master in my mind of
boundary walking i'd love to hear
what you think
has
has led you and this also made me think
of how people some people describe you
as clairvoyant when you're discussing
the astrology and the palmistry because
of your adeptness in this boundary area
or what types of structured thinking or
or lend themselves to your ability to
write speculative fiction you might say
the lack of the qualities that make it
difficult for me to write science
fiction
which i read a lot of plus plus dragons
you know i'm keen on dragons me too i
just cannot do them
so there are some things that you can
that you can do they have the ability to
do and other things that you may admire
but you cannot do
dragons outside my range of capabilities
in any way or so lucay le guin has kind
of sewed up dragons she got sort of the
dragon franchise
best dragons yeah so game of thrones the
dragons are basically sort of like
bazookas but her dragons have a great
intellect and different powers and other
things that aren't usually attributed to
dragons in the english tradition but
they are in the chinese tradition etc we
could go on about that but we won't
today
now you wanted to know sort of what's
behind it what's yeah what's behind this
bucket of fiction
what makes you get at it i grew up in
the in the 50s as a teenager and i read
a lot of those things so i read 1984
just after it came out
so i read it in the paperback version
with the typically sleazy cover of the
early 50s they put classics into these
quite what shall we say about those
covers they made you think that you were
buying a really trashy book so i think a
lot of people got enticed into reading
like war and peace and things because
they thought it was about ladies and
negligees lying on
so my copy of 1984 had this this woman
with an enormous cleavage in the
foreground and and the guy standing
behind her looking down her front which
does get in there a bit but that's not
the general import i've mainlined all of
those books i've i've read ray bradbury
a lot you'll notice that i ended up
writing in one of his obits i think for
the guardian i went to comic-con for the
first time because we thought we were on
our way to see ray
but but unfortunately he died before we
got there so we ended up having a
memorial service at comic-con for
ray bradbury one of the great inventors
in several fields really read all of
those things john windham i was reading
in the 50s and i think what you read as
a teenage person often goes on to
influence what you are then writing when
you're able to you know when you have
these skills
so i think i had it in my mind for a
while i would like to write
a 1984 only with women
like that
so meanwhile along comes ursula k and uh
a number of other uh people that i was
following it's it's part what you're
drawn to and partly what you have the
skills to do as i say i can't do dragons
well i can't do dragons or speculative
fiction so you have me beat
i can't do podcasts well you know
podcasts are just ephemera in the mist i
think you that your your works will have
much more permanence but i can hope i
can hope that someday the audio will
have the same get locked in the amber in
the same way that words are i'm sure it
will
i want to i want to go back in time from
your teenage years
because i was i've read about your
experience of growing up in a cabin in
the woods and some of the benefits of
that the lack of distractions giving you
the concentration that perhaps helped
you become a writer later and so on
i'm
thinking about having kids in the very
near future
and i fantasize about living in the
woods because i feel most at home in the
woods
were there any downsides okay which
woods are you thinking of tim
i like
uh varied terrain so i i would prefer
something that isn't flat so we could
think uh american west we could thank
upstate new york we could thank british
columbia in certain locations
i would prefer not to hear or see any
neighbors
i would like to have lots
of
trails
that i can explore with my dog or dogs
or
family
and
running water
of some type and a lake or a pond having
access to both of those or one of those
at least so that's that is my i grew up
i grew up on long island more or less in
the woods okay uh but and and so that's
that's my idealized version but i don't
know what it's like to raise kids in the
woods i'm curious if there are any
downsides well you should ask my mom
except
she's not here
but uh i can tell you what jay said
yes please so my mom was an unusual
person liked being outdoors most of the
time
she was very athletic
she grew up in rural nova scotia she was
a big horse person she loved horses she
had horses
and she rode them heather and thither
and she was also
a speed skater
and of course a skier and
this kind of thing so i think she
married my dad because he was
a very bushy guy
and he grew up and grew up in even more
rural nova scotia like really rural
so they were so rural that i don't think
they got electricity until the late 50s
so i i was lucky enough to be able to
see a 19th century farm operating pretty
much the way it would have done
i think she who didn't like
hats little white gloves tea parties
didn't fancy it she liked dancing like
fast and furious waltzing and things
like that square dancing but she didn't
like the frilly part
and up in the woods was great for her
because she said you didn't actually
have to do much housework you just swept
the dirt out the door you didn't have to
worry about you know all of the stuff
that people have in their houses usually
like brickabrack and china and things
like that you don't have to worry about
those
so she didn't
and
she doesn't seem to have had
a problem in the woods except my brother
almost drowned once because he got out
and fell off the dock but apart from
that
and a few other somewhat hairy moments
[Laughter]
it was probably safer on the whole than
being in a city
anyway she seems to have managed pretty
well although some of her city friends
because they were in cities during the
winter
okay my dad was a forest entomologist it
meant
he was up in the woods when the insects
were doing things
but as a rule in fact
you could take it as almost 100
they don't do much in the winter
insects
pretty quiet insect wise in the winter
so they would go up and say april or so
and they would go back in for instance
november but this is i think quite a lot
further north than you were thinking of
being in the woods
tim i think you're thinking of a more
southerly location it is yeah i think
probably not you know baffin island or
anything like that uh no they weren't up
there and there aren't any trees there i
know i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
it's like to live in trees he was a
forest entomologist right so there had
to be a forest there had to be the
forest yeah they had running water but
it was out of a pump
and they didn't have electricity wow and
the transportation was by boat so
no roads wow
you could get to i think by 1939 there
was this horrible road which i remember
very well you'd always get carsick going
over it
and then you get to a place where you
left the car and then you'd get in a
boat
so then it was during the war so there
weren't even a lot of motor boats
because gasoline was rationed
so canoes
i would love to hear you describe an
experience that came up in my reading it
relates to a day you found yourself
walking across a football field oh yeah
i don't know if that's enough of a queue
yeah yeah but i would love to hear you
expand on this because i did read about
it but i i feel like there's probably
more to the story so could you please
just provide sure some color and tell
the story writers make stuff up tim
you you ask them questions that
essentially have no answers but they
make stuff up anyway so i'll tell you
what i made up yes please but it's kind
of true
sounds like my life
yeah right it's like that
mostly kind of true yeah sort of true
your previous question what did growing
up in the woods have to do with being a
writer there wasn't anything to do
except
yeah when it was raining except
reading writing and and drawing
so there were no other
things to do like no theaters no schools
no television no
what else can you think of none of those
things
so therefore i fixated on writing pretty
early
and
it was a narrative family people told
stories
and my older brother was a gung-ho
writer he wrote lots of things at that
age he turned into a scientist but
he was very narrative
when he was a
10
9.
anyway back to the football field there
i am
uh having written my first novel at the
age of seven it was about an ant
some
structural difficulties there tim
because ants don't do anything until
they're in the fourth stage of their
life so
they don't do anything when they're an
egg they don't do anything when they're
a larva they do nothing when they're a
pupa and it's only when you get to you
know the last part of the story that
they actually have any legs so i don't
start books that way anymore tim
but i did then so then i stopped writing
i i
took to drawing i drew a lot
and
then i ended up in high school
at slightly too early in age
uh they skipped people then
i think they've stopped doing that so i
was 12 and some of the people in my
class were almost 16 because they failed
people then tim
so it was a slightly daunting experience
but you can imagine but things evened
out after that yes i was quite short in
fact i'm still quite short
people got bigger
for a while i was sort of normal size
but that's no longer true
there's all these you know enormous kids
who drank a lot of
milk with vitamins in it
anyway there i was in high school
and uh i love my grade 11 teacher that
would be
one two the third year of high school
what do you call that
in this day is it something else uh i
guess junior junior year but we've what
do you guys call it fifth form i don't
know if you use british system i have no
idea no that's english what do you guys
call it in canada well we called it
different grades like 9 10 11 12 and in
those days 13 but they've done away with
that yeah we would call it 11 probably i
guess 11th or junior year
junior yeah so my great
english teacher who i put in a book
which is a peculiar
people go back and they do documentaries
about you right and usually the teacher
says oh yes i could see instantly great
brilliant shawn right out of her head
and i can tell she was you know slated
for greatness but she told the truth she
said she showed no particular ability in
my glass which was true i didn't show
any particular ability in her class
and i had no idea then that i was going
to be a writer
didn't strike me
until the next year
when i had a different english teacher
who i've also put into a story because
she was a
a legend in her own time she
she she took hold of the people in her
class and she
yanked them through the curriculum
no matter what no matter what she got us
through
and her name was miss bessie billings
and she made the immortal comment
because i showed her one of my poems she
said
i don't understand this at all dear so
it must be good
so wonderful i love it that is great
that is great yeah so i started writing
poetry in in grade
12
and the story i tell about that is that
i was crossing the football field and
a pink princess line dress that i had
sewed myself
a work of art tim
you don't know what that is do you
oh i can envision based on some of the
words what it might look like princess
line it had these panels and then it
sort of flared out
anyway it was great loved it i kept the
button
i had a beautiful sort of button on the
front which i still have
oh yes well i'd made a terrible mistake
i'd gone into home economics instead of
the
secretarial sciences which i should have
done
had i known i would have done that and
then i would know how to touch type
which i don't
and it's too late now tim
so there i was in my pink princess line
dress crossing the football field and
a poem occurred to me
it wasn't a very good poem but it was a
poem i was very excited about it
and this is how these things start
you write some pretty terrible poetry
that you're very excited about
and luckily there's nobody there to tell
you this is really terrible poetry
and then you go on from there
what did it feel like when this poem
came to you i mean the the lie now you
can tell me how much of this is uh
you know a sort of a revisionist history
and storytelling and how much of it is a
reflection of your experience but
quote a large invisible thumb descended
from the sky it's the eureka moment tim
yeah a big thumb came out of the sky if
you believe that what else would you
like me to tell you that you will also
believe well i already asked about
astrology so you got me
you can tell me anything yes it was very
interesting to me
and uh i had been trying out these
potential careers like i was going to be
a a painter and then i revised that i
was going to be a fashion designer and
then i revised that and i went into home
economics because in the
textbook was called guidance
in grade nine you were supposed to
decide what your career was going to be
can you imagine who knows anything when
they're that old oh yeah
yeah not me so the guidance textbook had
had five things that that girls could do
and they did not include astrophysicist
let's see if you can guess what they
were in 1952
i think i can but i'm cheating nurse
secretary school teacher airline
stewardess as they were known and home
economist you've read what i wrote
i know i'm a bad shooter i am a very
good cheater
you didn't get away with that
oh yeah i know yes that's what was on
offer and being a mercenary child i
looked up what they made
because i did grow up in a family in
which it was expected that you would
support yourself
so
the home economists made the most
believe it or not so i went into that
but then i decided no this is not for me
i'm going to be a
biologist i was going to be a botanist
because i was actually quite good at it
and but then along came this writing
and
much to my parents dismay but
being the bite your tongue kind of
parents i think they just hoped it would
be a phase that i would grow out of it
it's been a long phase
okay yeah well they did say the very
practical thing right off the bat they
said well how are you going to support
yourself i said you know i'll get a job
which i did i got lots of jobs and then
my mother said rather caustically
if you're going to be a writer you
better learn to spell
and i said others will do that for me
and you know they have
now we have spell check
[Music]
all good things come to those who wait i
guess
you were right had to wait a while but
yeah it's been panned out so you you
wrote
if i'm getting the chronology right you
wrote for 16 years before you could make
a living out of it that's right you had
all these different jobs as you
mentioned yes there's a cashier in a
coffee shop and many others
over those 16 years did you were you
maintaining the belief that someday it
would pay the bills and
you would be able to make a living out
of it or was it just a labor of love
while you did these other things oh the
writing yes you mean did i ever think i
would make a living out of it no
people in my age group in my country at
that time didn't think that way
they might have thought that way in the
30s
and even in the 40s where there were a
couple of bestsellers written
by people in our country but right after
the
war during the 50s
a couple of things had happened
and one of them was that the paperback
book industry had taken off
and i think it started with the penguin
in the uk and then it was
pocketbooks
and
and canada didn't have
it had some nascent book publishers but
paperbacks were not included in them
so
the
glossy magazine
market was also drying up so a writer
like morley callahan who wrote a lot of
short stories in the 20s and 30s made a
living out of selling two glossies
but that was that was dwindling by that
time some of them still existed but
but not in the same way that
that they had
so we weren't really thinking in those
terms and there there were no
agents in canada at that time we we
didn't even really quite understand what
they were
there were some publishers but they
didn't publish very many canadian books
because it was thought there wasn't a
market for them
so if you wanted to publish a novel your
publisher would say well we have to get
a partner you know either in london or
in new york
and that was easier
said than done so the the book
publishing that had been going on in the
30s of cheap hardbacks kind of dried up
in fact let me just be
a little more certain about that it was
gone having had paperbacks take its
place
so it was hardbacks
and
i've always been interested in the
underpinnings to all of these things in
fact i was associated with a small
publishing company
in the
late
60s and early 70s
and a lot of it was about money
like how many can we sell what can we
what can we publish
to support these works of
cutting-edge
cutting-edge experimental fiction that
nobody's going to buy
uh what can we publish so we we did we
published the first book on venereal
disease it was called
vd
these these were so you know idiots
guides these were sort of idiots guides
before there were idiots guides
we got as far as warts
but we didn't get to aids because nobody
knew about it yet like that so let me
let me hop in for just a second when
you're writing for 16 years not thinking
you can make a living from it that's
right
what did you get from the writing and
did you share your writing with anyone
oh absolutely we were all loved sharing
our stuff around
because we were
editing each other's work
we were publishing each other's work
we were
all of the the poets were connected
through this kind of
spider web network of little magazines i
got it yeah both in canada the u.s
england there were these little
magazines
that published uh poetry and people
knew each other through them so the the
poets knew one another before the
novelists did in our country the poets
were more peripatetic
they would get on the greyhound bus and
turn up at your door
and sleep on your rug
and you and your turn might
get on the greyhound bus and and turn up
at somebody else's door and sleep on
their rug so it was a sort of a rug
exchange
of poets
they would turn up here and there and
give readings in out of the way places
and uh
some of them
there do you remember no you don't sorry
coffee shops
coffee shop readings i know coffee shops
no i i do i do i haven't been to a
coffee shop
let me not say shops that's it should be
houses oh yes so
they didn't have liquor licenses so
basically people brought flasks in their
handbags pockets and
things like that and you had the usually
condemned warehouse or something and
the little
tables with the
checkered tablecloths the little
wine bottles with the candle stuck in
them
and the open mic
so poetry night usually on a tuesday
sounds great that sounds like a lot of
fun down part of the week all the folk
singing and jazz went on on on other
nights of the week such as thursday
friday and saturday that's how they you
know
supported the poetry meetings
so we did that in the
early 60s
and then the poetry readings spread to
universities some of them and then to
bookstores they decided that they could
do that too
and the big festivals didn't
start happening until the
mid-70s i would say
all of these festivals that you see
proliferating like mushrooms all around
or you did see it before covet
they didn't exist yet
they sprang up out of the subculture of
coffee houses
and this this is neither here nor there
but i am fascinated actually by the
history of coffee houses especially in
the uk where you have
lloyds of london coming out of one
coffee shop and all of this incredible
uh history that i had really no glimpse
oh you mean back in the 18th century
yeah
yes way back which i also don't remember
to be clear but i have read about it and
that interchange of ideas and this the
the uh the sort of interstitial tissue
in the in the societal fabric of the
time
but
what i'd like to ask you about next is
teaching and
it's clear reading about your life that
you have taught a lot
what type of teaching did you most enjoy
if any of it i always enjoyed it
i think the most intense year of
teaching that i did was in montreal i
thought it's a place that doesn't exist
anymore because it's been amalgamated
with another institution but it was
called sir george williams
and it was a downtown city establishment
and
you taught your subject to
19 year olds in the day
and then in the evening you taught the
same subject to returning adult students
that was very instructive for me
the 19 year olds weren't too sure why
they were there
except their mom and dad wanted them to
and really they would rather be drinking
beer or going to hockey games or
something
and the adults were there because they
wanted to be
a couple of reasons they wanted to be
there they wanted to up their
credentials but also they were very
engaged and they would argue with you
and
object to things and you know really
really give you the old run through and
that was pretty stimulating
so i taught 19th century
uh novels to those
people and i also taught um american
romanticism
and it was they who gave me a button
that said moby dick is not a social
disease
so they had a sense of humor i
i liked them a lot
and it was very instructive because the
things that the
that the 19 year old likes liked
frequently the grown-ups would not like
and the things that the
19 year olds really didn't like the
grown-ups thought
were terrific
so middle march by george eliot the 19
year old said uh oh this is we don't
like this book at all because the people
in it
make wrong decisions in their careers
and they marry the wrong people and
we're not going to do that
and the adult said this is a great book
they
make the wrong decisions in their
careers they marry the wrong people it's
just like life
so a big difference in experience and
what's the lesson the lesson is that you
bring to any book who you already are
at the age that you are in the
experience that you've had and it's the
same for
everyone
so we're talking about books of course
i'll segue to a book that i've not read
and i'd love to ask you about because
you've recommended that young adults
should read the future of life by edmund
osborne wilson if the internet is to be
believed
yes unfortunately he's just died that's
right i've actually put a quote
of
e.o wells and i guess as i as i better
know him
in
my newsletter in fact i guess two weeks
ago
why do you recommend the future of life
yeah he's a biologist i was familiar
with his work from
from an early period because of course
he was an entomologist he was he was an
ant guy
and my dad started out as a bee guy
and as you will know from your deep
study of entomology
those are both hymenoptera
of course
so my dad was was very interested in his
work on ants and i read it pretty early
on
and i followed him along and i was in
fact the reviewer
for his only novel
and you can probably find that review in
the new york review of books
and i was
well equipped to do it because i knew
about ants
and the the central section of that book
which is the life and death of an ant
colony is the most gripping one you
think wow this is so epic it's like the
sack of troy i actually knew him a bit i
met him i thought he was
very interesting he was a huge advocate
for the future of life on earth early an
early advocate and a lot of the early
advocates for the kind of things that we
are now very concerned about now
they came from the world of biology
so my parents for instance were early
sierra club
and early
environmentalists and
very clear
from any study of biology
life is interconnected
so you contain multitudes tim
just telling you
thank you i'm still i'm still
investigating but yes i tend to i tend
to agree with you
[Laughter]
maybe not in the way you think
almost certainly
not in the way i think yes i'm sure you
contain many personalities but i'm i'm
thinking more of your microbes but never
mind
you could not exist without them
now that is actually something that i
spend quite a bit of time thinking about
the microbiome and the the exobiome
i do yes it's well so the knowledge has
percolated out from the biologists into
the podcast
somehow yes i'm not going to be writing
any books about it but somehow these
things do happen
i would love to
chat with you about something that i
think a lot of my listeners will be very
interested in certainly i'll be
interested in exploring a bit and and
that is
what seems like a predilection to resist
labels and or being labeled being
claimed for causes you wrote an essay
titled on being a woman writer which got
a lot of attention is it fair to say
that you resist
labels being labeled and if so
why
why is that how would you explain that i
resist closed boxes
okay
the reason i resist closed boxes is that
nature does not deal in closed boxes
yeah it doesn't if if it did there
wouldn't have been any evolution
if it did you and i would not exist
so everything in nature is on a bell
curve
and uh there are a lot of
liminal beings or let's say
forms that cannot be put into closed
boxes
such as for instance the platypus
so i just don't like closed boxes and
labels are a way of of filing people
you know oh you're at this we're gonna
file you there
and under this you know
letter
your box is going to go there and that's
who you are and that's all you are and
and i don't think that's true of anyone
and i do think we all contain multitudes
so that's probably why and you you can
say sure i'm a woman writer i'm a woman
i'm a writer
but that's not the end of the story
there have been a lot of women writers
and not all of them are exactly like me
so we we don't
you can you can put a general heading
over something just as you can put a
general heading over
science fiction
speculative fiction stories about
werewolves
you know dracula frankenstein ghost
stories they're all wonder tales
you can call them all wonder tales so
you can call all women writers women
writers but that's not the end of the
story
there's a lot of other things
that can be added to that
so
dracula is not the same as
war of the worlds
they're both wonder tales but they're
very different
like that
so sure let's say
woman writer 82
generational okay
country
city
height
hair curly
that's important tim yeah
so like that so you can you can build
out the picture you can you can start
with a few
labels but it's not the whole story for
anybody
and if you're a novelist of course you
deal in individuals
so you're not just doing types
does that make any sense to you
it makes perfect sense it makes perfect
sense and it's
you know i think that
labels are also dangerous because if you
assume them for yourself
you're more inclined if you get attached
to them to want to defend
those labels as a facet or as the sole
entirety of your
identity and that's i think how we end
up in a lot of the places where we find
ourselves collectively now yeah well
people attach labels to other people and
then they attack the label and that has
been going on for at least 5 000 years
as far as we know yeah a few years
yeah quite a few years so that's that's
a thing that if we wish to live in them
in a
multiple democracy
we should
attempt to go beyond labels
and of course what people then go is
well you're a feminist and then i always
have to say what kind of feminist are
you talking about right because there's
at least 75 different kinds
so am i the kind that thinks all men
should be rounded up and shoved off a
cliff except for 10 kept for breeding no
i am not that kind
you will be happy to note him
yes i think you're happy to know
that you want to be kept for breeding do
you no you don't i want to be kept for
breeding yes please keep me from
breeding
maybe not maybe not depends on the it
really depends on how that's all
organized
yeah you know i should probably think
more before i answer these types of
things but
[Laughter]
you know you you strike me as a very
joyful person before we started
recording
i said i didn't want to bore you and you
said i'm never bored
one might say and again this is applying
a label but that you're
you've long been interested in what
people might consider dystopian
literature you bet you seem to be a
connoisseur of possibly dystopian
speculative fiction
utopian too yeah utopian do you consider
yourself and and i am asking you to use
a label so pardon me but
generally speaking an optimistic
or hopeful person
i think hope is built in
on a very fundamental level too
to human beings because
we get up in the morning and
if we thought it was going to be a
horrible day every day we probably
wouldn't bother doing that yeah
and some people are afflicted you know
they are they're they've got depression
and it's just a horrible thing to live
with so there is a difference between
sad and being depressed so of course i'm
sad about various things but but i'm
also i'm hopeful about our species
in that
although we have lots of downsides
which we know about
through history and looking around you
and
reading dystopian fiction we know we're
capable of really awful things
uh we're also capable of really
pretty
wonderful things and we're
we're smart and inventive
so yes we're facing a climate crisis
it's real we're also inventing a lot of
things
having to do with that we are looking at
the problem and we are coming up with
the solutions
and that's very interesting to me and
it's why i'm doing this
program called practical utopias
so the 19th century was a big century of
utopias they
they wrote a lot of them
because they had made so many
improvements already in the 19th century
that they thought why this is just going
to go on and it's going to get better
and better and better
but then along comes the first world war
bloodshed slaughtered
mustard gas and all kinds of awful
things
and then along come
various
totalitarianisms and the
second world war so people aren't
writing utopias much in the 20th century
they're writing a lot of dystopias
things could get much worse instead of
things could be a lot better
so i'm doing practical utopias
to bring together a lot of this thinking
that's been going on about not how to
make a utopia in which everything is
perfect we we don't get to have that
human beings are
are different
fallible and they don't always agree on
what is better but we're going to have
to think of different ways to live if we
are going to
overcome the crisis that is
facing us
and short form is the oceans die we're
gone
sorry
we're gonna have to deal with that tim
let's expand on practical utopia so
practical utopias yes and then the
subheading or description and
exploration of the possible this is an
eight week
if i understand correctly live online
learning experience it is how did you
choose this project of all of the things
that you could spend time on why is this
important to you i think it's important
to to us
i think it's important in the general
scheme of things and at the point at
which we are now finding ourselves
and we know what the problems are
because we we carp about them endlessly
it's it's important to
turn people's minds to
to what can be done
apart from blanket statements like we
all have to not use gasoline anymore
so
there is going to have to be a
transitional period about that tim
right
so getting people together gathering
people who know something about these
fields
and uh putting putting them together
with people are knowledgeable in other
fields
and constructing
you know lego
making a lego village you know minecraft
so world building in a practical way
what are we gonna eat
what sort of clothes are we gonna wear
what are we going what are they going to
be made out of
what sort of houses will we live in
what about vertical farms i'm really
interested in vertical farms right now
how about mushrooms
did you know you can make
bricks out of mushrooms would you like
to have a mushroom coffin bricks bricks
yes
yeah yeah you better join up you know
you can 3d print houses out of
compressed earth
in two days do you know that there are
now prefab houses
that you can erect
that
create more energy than they consume
so all of these ideas brought together
and for the practical utopia it's going
to have to be the solutions will have to
be green
they'll have to be cheap enough and
they'll have to be scalable
so these are this is a problem-solving
enterprise and we can look at some of
the things that went
pear-shaped about previous attempts to
make utopias
and we're going to have to build in the
social component to try to keep that
from happening like how do you
how do you take something with with
great idealism attached like the early
stages of the
russian revolution and keep it from
turning into stalin show trials
like that you know a lot about the
russian revolution what might be some of
your observations with respect to the
example you just gave
and the russian revolution well it's not
just the russian it's the french
the american one is a bit of an anomaly
because it was not conducted in a
confined space as it were
and
it was a particular
kind of revolution that was not so much
overthrowing a ruling classroom within
as ejecting a ruling class that was
coming in from without
so that's a different kind of thing
so
with the with the french and the the
russian they were toppling
a ruling class from within
and uh
the way that both of those things went
is is
very interesting
to me and and then you find him you
reach a point where it all falls apart i
mean the other example of course is is
um are hitler and mussolini on on the
right the french and the russian i guess
you would say were from the left so how
do you keep those things from sort of
falling apart and
turning into the terror and the show
trials and uh
the cultural revolution and things like
that
in fact one of these books no one it's
not under there anymore it's around here
somewhere
it's over here
great book on the um
chinese cultural revolution by a guy who
was there
what's the title the world turned upside
down it's by yang jisheng
the most interesting part for me is is
how they went about toppling the gang of
four
they actually did maiden houses and
write things on little pieces of paper
which they then burned because they were
convinced their houses were bugged which
they were
[Music]
so high drama yeah eye drama sort of
george smiley
territory
you know what you were gonna there have
been multiple times when you have said
do you remember that and then you said
of course you don't because i was not
alive who is george smiley i'm going to
admit ignorance on this one george
smiley is john the correso tinker taylor
soldiers by ah
got it mi6
guy who sets out to catch a mole
a mole from within the intelligence
service what was the film it's a tv
series starring alec guinness which is
very good at it too
from about the 70s early 70s
you can find it
with the cursor research
of
web streamers
yeah there's a fantastic film depth of
the cold war yeah yeah that's the cult
where there's another film that might
sort of tie into that example one of my
favorite films actually certainly for a
long period of time called the lives of
others fantastic film exactly which was
about the monitoring of east berlin
residents by the stasi
incredible film i lived in west berlin
in 1984 and went across to
east berlin and also in czechoslovakia
and also poland very instructive
you had to be quite careful
how you talked to people if they would
talk to you
and those three
countries were very different
so the one that was sewed up the
tightest was east germany
the one that was quite loosey-goosey was
poland
so you're going to be bringing your life
experience your study of history
to bear on practical utopias
how many other people are involved what
does the structure
look like so we're doing it with a
platform called disco
which is an interactive live learning
platform
and um
it's structured so that
they give you the tools
so you know what sub stack is i do so
substack gives you the tools to
basically publish your own newspaper and
and disco gives you the tools to do your
own live learning experience
so there are there are other kinds of
learning experience which are
like ted talks and things and master
class which i did one of
and they're more like
films
in fact the background of the master
class people was in film production and
they do a beautiful
job of film producing
your class
the
disco one is is interactive in that
people join you
and there's a to and fro so
the the idea is that people will bring
their ideas to add to the building of
their version of
a better way to live
that will be green scalable and
affordable and they're going to have to
make practical decisions they're going
to say they're going to have to say okay
which is better
is it better to get your corpse disposed
of by cremation
very carbon producing is it better to
put it in a mushroom coffin is it better
to
do this new thing that has started up in
seattle called recompose in which you
you get turned quite quickly into
compost
and they're going to have to do the
cost and money and the cost and carbon
and figure out which choice they're
going to make because there's there's
ups and downs to all of these choices
so what you're going to eat
are you going to eat
100 mile diet are you going to grow
things in vertical gardens quite close
to you
is it going to be nothing but
brown rice
it wasn't about 1973 that was very bad
for people
so you're gonna have to do the nutrition
plus where are you getting these things
and we are so used to going into the
supermarket and everything is just there
you know
yeah
how long can that continue and all of
these things what are you going to do
with the old people are you going to
sort of shove them out the window at
some point or what
don't laugh
it's been done i'll make you a deal if i
am kept as one of the 10 or 20 of males
for breeding i will prevent them from
throwing you out the window
so i can strike a bargain
now you have a lot going on you also
have
burning questions yes collection of
essays from 2004 to 2021 which will be
uh published in march of 2022.
could you tell us more about burning
questions
so it's the third in the series and
there's two been two other collections
of
of essays
uh the original one was called second
words because it was mostly book reviews
i did a lot of book reviews
at that time
the second one was called moving targets
and that took us from
that took us up to 2004
and then we have burning questions and
to to do these collections we have to
weed through an awful lot of stuff
because it turns out that i write about
on an average of 35 short pieces a year
so you can see that adds up i know it's
awful now when you say short pieces what
do you consider short
what is the range on shirt well anywhere
from you know four pages to
two 25 pages
wow okay well some of them are speeches
you know they they can they can dribble
on for a while
but some of them are
and you have to condense them you have
to take out the repetitions
increasingly of course
they're obituaries of people that i have
known
i didn't write any of those in the first
part of my life because nobody died
that i knew yeah
so there are some of those i i did
well we won't go into all the people
that have died but
but i have written some of their obits
i wrote actually two for ursula k le
guin i wrote one for the guardian i
wrote one for the
washington post and they they both had
to be different
but these things are very sudden you
know somebody's suddenly dead and they
want you to write it right now so i i
wrote one of those on a plane
so that's what it is and
quite a lot about
conservation issues which have come
increasingly to the fore
as usual gender issues
and um
and other
things that you might not
expect nor did i i didn't expect them
either but suddenly there i was writing
about them
is burning questions
taken from one of the pieces that was
included in the collection otherwise
where did the title come from oh i think
it just came out of the air like like a
lot of titles
like that big thumb in the sky
like that yes exactly like that
it's suddenly just there
i think the issues that we are facing
although we have
been in these very tight spots before i
can remember sitting in
cambridge massachusetts at the time of
the cuban missile crisis thinking that
we were all going to get atom bombs
dropped on us at any minute
that didn't happen but i think it came
pretty close
so like that
things that that almost
happened but but didn't
and i'm hoping that the climate
crisis although it's already uh underway
i'm i'm hoping that it can be at least
installed
enough for people to get a grip on it
yeah that's certainly a subject area and
a research area that i'm spending a lot
of my time on as well right now that you
are well you should join practical
utopias come and join us you probably by
this time have gathered a lot of things
every every day there's something new
that comes into view
for instance i hadn't been thinking at
all about about vertical farms and now i
am i'm suddenly doing a lot of thinking
about about how and there's a number of
companies putting this together for you
there's a bunch of kits out there
things like that did you know you can
make fabric out of algae
i did not know about the fabric no
neither did i but now i do
but it's so funny that you mentioned
algae
i was just going to say as as one of my
examples in the last six months is
aquaculture so vertical sea farming
and uh specifically algae i didn't know
about the application of clothing so no
i did not know that it's the hemp of the
sea i guess yes well the clothing and
you know growing cotton growing stuff
that you make fabrics out of is is
pretty consumptive of of energy and
materials and waters
so how do we deal with with these things
now i i i want to push back on a quote
that i read from you uh
at some point when prepping for this and
it was it was related to i believe an
interviewer or someone profiling you
saying that you were prolific and you
said i believe and this could be a
misquote but
joyce carol oates is prolific i'm just
old
i mean you have a great sense of humor
so i can see it now especially having
spent some time together how you would
say something like that
i would say that you are most certainly
prolific but it mounts up you see it
just accumulates so you know john john
keats was probably more prolific but he
died young
so there's there's there's two things
there's the accumulation which makes you
look prolific but then there's the speed
the the rate
which can actually be quite slow but if
but if you're
this old and it all sort of adds up
has your writing
cadence or your writing habits changed
much over the last
few decades or have they remained fairly
constant no no of course they change
so when you have a job
you're right at night
yeah so when you have a job when you're
a student
those kinds of things you're going to be
a night writer
when you have a child
when the child is small
if you still have a brain at that point
and it does come back
you are going to write when the child is
asleep
when the child goes to school you're
going to write when the child is at
school
when the child
sniffle sniffle sniffle goes off on its
own grows up and goes off on its own
then you're probably and and you're
getting quite
dare i say middle aged
yes i'm going to say middle age to
getting it out there already
you're probably going to be
writing in the day time
then there's another thing that happens
uh when you pass a certain
moment which you seem to need less sleep
so right now i'm a procrastinating
nighttime writer
in other words i'm back to doing what i
used to do in about 1964.
what does it look like when you write at
night is it a set block of time a set
number of pages
i i know that you as i understand it
don't have any
sort of magical talismans you don't have
a particular writing setup that you
require
but what what is it in the last just say
a handful of years what does your night
writing look like
so many pages is usually how i do it
so not so much time
and that's that's motivating
because if you write the number of pages
that you think you should be writing
that day
you can then goof off
and watch
really silly murder mysteries tim
uh signed me up i was just doing it on
netflix the other day
what were you watching i was watching
in the dark which is a series about
a very a very attractive blind woman who
is attempting to solve a murder mystery
and it's very funny oh that's the audrey
hepburn plot from uh
long ago what is that movie that she was
in
oh boy i don't know
wait until dark
there we go that's what it is wait until
dark she's blind the guy comes in the
house is going to murder her and she
shuts off all the lighting
so that she
can get around better than he can oh wow
and uh that goes back to i think an h.d
wells story called in the valley of the
blind the one-eyed man is king
which is a sci-fi story
in which he this guy thinks he's pretty
you want to hear the plot yeah i do i do
want to hear the plot yes he strays into
a valley in which everybody is blind
in fact they don't even have any eyes
they just have sort of blank spaces
there and not even any sticky out things
and he he decides that he can be king of
this because he can see
and he falls in love with the
woman he says
yes yes we can get married but first we
have to get rid of those
ugly bumps on your face
wait a minute
i'm gone
[Laughter]
[Music]
it makes me think of that that twilight
zone episode i can't recall the name of
the episode but the it's very sort of
anti-social i guess this is sort of a
redundant way to put it but misanthrope
this man
who wears glasses
who survives the end of the world and
now he can be alone and read all of his
books and he steps on his own glasses at
the end of the episode oh no oh no
yes sad christmas i guess
well margaret
this has been so much fun
people should certainly check out
practical utopias an exploration of the
possible we'll link to that in the
show notes at tim.blog podcast so people
will be able to find that very easily
went to moving along to to launching in
september because we got too much
there's too much input
so we just needed a bit more time and
we also decided to add a low
cost
nft
you know what an nft is i do i do know
what an energy is you do well we're
doing them at first they said let's do
one of those and i said we can't do that
because they consume too much energy
like a lot
so they went out and they found one that
doesn't it's consumed the same amount of
energy as a tweet
and it is called a
t-e-z-o-s
oh tezos
tezos
yes i know tezus you do what do you know
about it tim
well i know that
many
creatives artists of different types
decide to use tezos and
by extension some of them use a
marketplace called han
they're different
different tools and platforms related to
this but
it is an alternative for those who are
seeking a less energy intensive way of
engaging with the nft the non-fungible
token
space so what we are doing we're hiring
graphic illustrators
to draw the utopias
so each of our interactive groups is
going to have make choices about how
they're
how their utopia is going to be and
these illustrators are going to
illustrate them
and i'm going to do some illustrating of
them too because
one of my background things as a graphic
design
and comic book writing
tim
pretty elementary kind so we're going to
get some wonderful illustrators
and they're going to make five
illustrations for each of our utopias
and we're going to put them into these
nfts
and this is a whole new world for me
but one of our team members knows quite
a lot about it
in fact he is an nft artist himself so
he just gave us a crash course last week
on
how this works
what it could look like and
how it's all going to come together so i
think that part is pretty exciting and i
have worked with graphic artists before
they live in a wild and wonderful world
probably know that i did have
i did what was essentially a bird
conservation project called angel cat
bird
with a wonderful graphic artist called
johnny christmas
yes i do
and that was so much fun
and we exchanged ideas through through
drawing them and sending them over the
internet
so he would send me one and i would say
make the ears bigger
i send him a cat skeleton
you know this is a cat skeleton you have
to look at the skull it's very narrow at
the bottom
so he he did a wonderful job
and
and i'm looking forward to seeing which
graphic artists our team member rick
manages to talk into doing this and they
will all be in these nif nfts nfts at
low energy cost that's the idea
yeah it's a fascinating space i think
it's also wonderful that you're
experimenting with some of these
alternative
platforms and
drawing some attention to different
options that people have in the space
yeah well i'm keen on disco because it
allows people who aren't in a physical
space
to participate
in an experience that that usually
people only had in in physical spaces
and that goes way back
to the beginning of the
21st century when i was trying to think
of a way to
to
make
book signings and author appearances
available to places that normally
wouldn't have them
and we did succeed in doing that the
enterprise was called long pen
but the publishing industry couldn't get
their heads around it so now it's segued
into
a business tool
with a different name it's called
s-y-n-g-r-a-f-i-i
and uh it is biometric digital signing
within a video signing room
but because we started it so early
we've got all these patents tim because
nobody else was doing it and people
thought we were nuts you've heard this
story before
sort of the velcro story like what is
this good for
well that's how a lot of things start
you know post-it notes would be another
example was it what did they think they
thought it was a flawed
doomed
failed adhesive because it didn't work
didn't it keep things stuck in one place
and then somebody said well wait a
second here maybe we can actually change
the positioning and there is an
application it's just not the
application that we're used to it's
actually the opposite of what we would
normally look for yes i use them a lot
in novel writing post-it notes
how do you use them in novel writing
well there's my
thing that i'm writing and then i have
an idea so i stick it on the table
oh yes
the idea on the table uh
well
i have been taking notes as we've been
talking i have so many things that i'm
going to be following up on ranging from
the world turned upside down to of
course practical utopia's burning
questions this collection of essays from
2004 to 2021 coming out march 2022
i feel like we could talk for many many
hours and for those people who didn't
catch it
and not only have you
produced
work and written in every possible
format or genre imaginable
because why not right
you understand why not i do
because why not
you also are an inventor because i think
people may have not
just in case they didn't get the
underscoring on that with patents with
this long pen originally long pen
technology allowing i guess it would be
remote robotic
writing well the physical long pen of
course that has we have an entirely
digital service now but the physical
long pen still exists and people still
want to have them yeah because you write
on your end
and the pen holder on the other end
duplicates that exactly with real inc so
yes it's bizarre but it came out of the
requirements of the book signing
industry because book collectors would
not accept anything that wasn't
perfectly your signature
and we did these events you know from
australia to north america
you know back and forth from england we
we were able to do it and people didn't
know how to scale it
but as it is now
it's all been solved so you can you can
do the digital version but if you need
the physical one with ink that can be
produced
but it's not like an auto pen an auto
pen is a is like a sewing machine
designed this is every
remember cursive
i do you're a signature every time you
sign your name it's it's different from
the last time you signed it
so i have just two more questions for
you one i'm going to warn people ahead
of time this has a bit of a spoiler so
fast forward 30 seconds if you don't
want a spoiler
of sorts
and this is on behalf of my employee i
mentioned who loves your work
and here's her question
when you wrote the handmaid's tale
decades ago did you plan aunt lydia's
role as a double agent which the rest of
us didn't find out until the testaments
or did she evolve as a character in the
space between the two books
she evolved for sure okay
no she's a she's a secondary character
in the handmaid's tale and she becomes a
primary character in the testaments
and the thing about
characters who speak for themselves
you're always a lot a lot closer to them
and and they're always more more complex
than somebody that you're just seeing
you know that's sort of across the room
and as you know from what i've
already said everybody is more complex
than
than just the sort of cardboard cutout
so
once we
get inside out lydia's head
she turns out to have quite a few more
dimensions and also it's further along
in the plot so
the testaments is
approx 15 16 years after the handmaid's
tale
things have happened to aunt lydia
since that time
so you know i always base things on
stuff that's happened
and one of my
go-to's for aunt lydia was was people
who
had been believers within a system and
then changed their minds
and there are a number of those in
history they're pretty interesting
and how do you go about doing
research for
characters like those in history or were
those already examples you had in mind
and therefore you didn't have to go
digging for them were they already
references in your head or did you do
research
okay so remember what i said about being
old
and stuff accumulating
yes so did you have a granny who had an
attic
i did
okay what was in it
i wasn't allowed up there so i don't
know oh darn
you weren't allowed up there well that's
very bad
everybody should be allowed up into
their granny's granny's attic once
because it's basically like a collection
of stuff that just it's there
like you put it up there because you
can't think of what else to do with it
but you don't want to throw it out so
the inside of my head is like that tim
so
there's just a lot of stuff
in there
and um
there's also a lot of books in this
house and and one of the sections is
devoted to
wars and totalitarianisms
and spies wow and really interesting
things like programs of deception
in
wars i mean i find those fascinating
the british hired a lot of theatrical
set designers
to to design illusions in the desert
make it look as if there were people
where there weren't people hide their
oil drums disguised trucks as tanks and
tanks as trucks and then they switched
them at night
so theatrical illusions so i had a lot
of it
already in the
junk shop of my brain
and
some of it in the war spies
totalitarianisms
section of my library
and some of it of course in shakespeare
you always go to shakespeare so richard
iii shakespeare a villain a villain who
tells us right off that he's really bad
and now we can watch him being bad
[Laughter]
margaret i don't even know how to begin
to
close up this conversation and you
contain multitudes
tim have i confused you
oh you've impressed me you haven't
confused me i think you've just
outranked me
i need to do a lot more reading so let's
have a little bit about you how did you
get into this what what put it into your
head to do a podcast
well the truth is i wrote books before
the podcast non-fiction books so i wrote
three of those and i i found the third
book to be
particularly
difficult and
it really took a lot out of me and in
the process of launching that third book
i ended up on a number of podcasts and i
really enjoyed the long form
conversation and i decided that i would
take a break from writing to
do six to ten episodes of a podcast with
my friends
to get better at asking questions
because with the nonfiction books i was
writing it it all came down to asking
questions of experts
at the end of the day so it seemed like
something that would transfer so i
decided to have
fun long conversations with friends to
hopefully get rid of some lazy verbal
tics and some lazy mental habits as a
consequence
and i just fell in love with
doing it it was for me
the
fun part of the research process without
the writing and i know that sounds
terrible but uh no it doesn't
at the time i was just so
battered and bruised from my experience
with this third book
and that's how the podcast started and
now we're almost 600 episodes in and
it's it is
it is something that gives me
incredible nourishment and energizes me
i was having such a
if i'm being honest terrible day before
we had this conversation i was i was
just having a brutal day and the last
week has been very difficult
and i feel great right now well that's
wonderful
and i think that's why i do the podcast
well i think that's a really good reason
so have you ever this is completely off
topic that's okay
do you know anything about
dictation apps in which you talk into
the
microphone and then it turns into text
i would like to start using such a
program because a friend of mine a new
friend named noah feldman who's a
professor at harvard law school
is a
he's just a prodigious talent and an
incredible writer and he uses i want to
say dragon which might have been
previously known as dragon naturally
speaking
to
draft everything that he writes articles
books and and so on why do you ask
well you know typing is hard
typing is hard especially if you can't
touch tight which i can't i have to look
so you know that they said of henry
james there were three
henry james as james the first james ii
and the old pretender
but late henry james dictated
hmm
did you know that
i did not know that
so people used to dictate to
stenographers but i don't think you can
i don't think those people exist anymore
but and also it would be a bit
inhibiting because there would be
another person in the room
don't you think
it would be inhibited yes yeah we knew a
person a long time ago who who wrote
romance novels and also drank and and
she used to sit behind a screen
and dictate her romance novels to a
stenographer it's like a confessional
yeah like the confessional
the voice would come from behind the
screen and she'd say and and latisha
with her flashing green eyes and these
denograts
um
a couple pages ago her eyes were blue
just well changed them
maybe i need a person like that
yeah so you're saying i should drink and
use some dictation software no not you
no no no you're not writing flashing
eyed romance novels no no you don't need
to do that but i think if you have an
ipad i think you can do this right yeah
oh for sure yeah i've been meaning to
test the software do you use dictation
software or anything like that no yeah
that's why i'm asking you
oh
i'll tell i'll test it out for you i'll
test it noah noah is a true believer and
he is extremely smart he says it takes a
little while we were just texting about
this the other week in fact to work out
the kinks and get comfortable but
he has
i believe it's carpal tunnel or some
type of issue with his hands
and his in his lower arms
whereby he he you really can't sit and
type for long periods of time well it's
a problem but he's a true believer with
the dictation software so i i give you
my word i will test it out and i will
let you know how the experiment goes and
what my what my pro and con evaluation
is i do write a lot in in longhand and i
can just read
the long hand rather than having to
transcribe it
oh yeah i think that's a brilliant idea
so i'll test the software
and let you know because i need someone
to hold me accountable so i will i will
do that i'll make that commitment it's
going to be me holding you accountable
well well i know that i've made a
promise and now even if you forget my
who i am tomorrow i will still feel
badly if i don't do it so i will uh
i will i will download some form of of
transcription
software and i will test it out and let
you know how that goes that'd be great
is there anything else you would like to
to say share questions you'd like to ask
requests of my audience
complaints about the podcast you'd like
to lodge publicly can you come over and
shovel the snow off my riff
you know i would love to
but i don't think i'm terribly close by
uh
if i were closer by i would be happy to
do that
where are you tim i am actually
in
the mountains and
uh there is quite a bit of snow it's
going to start snowing again very soon
and
i just love it here i absolutely love it
are you there to go skiing
i'm absolutely skiing i'm going on a
back country trip tomorrow for my first
time to learn how to skin
which i have never done before which is
putting on basically a
almost like a shark skin condom on your
skis so you can go uphill and then you
take them off and and you have alpine
skiing i'll be doing that for a few days
and
i find the
geography and the ecology here to be
just stunning it is
unlike any place i've ever spent an
extended period of time my girlfriend's
family
is here she grew up here
as that's another reason that i'm here
and
it's spectacular just being immersed in
the
enormity of nature here is
calming for me i'm reading a book right
now called arctic dreams by barry lopez
it was a friend oh he was yeah so one of
my little write-ups and burning
questions is barry
um he passed away so recently and i was
so sad to hear that i had been gifted of
wolves and men
and it absolutely
blew my mind great
it was such a beautifully written
meticulously researched book
and
arctic dreams
of course was was recommended and
recommended and recommended and i'd
never spent time near the polls but
recently had my first trip i was invited
by a friend to go to antarctica
and
became fascinated by these polar regions
and so
only in the last few weeks have i
started
arctic dreams
and the permanence that he writes about
and the vastness of some of those spaces
reminds me in a sense of the the western
united states at altitude and they're
very different very very very different
but you can get a taste of what he's
referring to in places like
montana certainly in alaska you can get
that feeling
so i'm i'm happy to be here i'm very
very happy to be here and where are you
at the moment
i'm sitting in my
study
which you can see in the background
in toronto but i i made it down from the
woods just in time for this
interview we had a blizzard yesterday so
i was supposed to come down yesterday
but we did not
take that chance
and uh made it down passing 12
stuck buses
on the way
and uh
made the interview hooray you made it
well thank you for putting in such an
incredible effort this was wonderful i
encourage people to
really do a deep dive on everything that
you're up to including practical utopias
and burning questions people can find
you online at margaret atwood dot ca on
twitter at margaret atwood instagram the
real margaret atwood
and
this has just been such a joy to spend
time with you this afternoon so thank
you very much margaret for for carving
out the space to have this conversation
and thank you it was a real pleasure and
uh enjoy your skiing
thank you
i will and uh to everybody listening
you contain multitudes to not be
contained by closed boxes that do not
conform to the greater beauty of nature
and be just a little bit kinder than you
have to be and until next time thank you
for tuning in
you